there are people wondering what happened
to the girl I used to be don't get too
comfortable black cake it's
unpredictable and even reading the
scripts I was like what this happens
every time you think you have it figured
out it turns a little bit more if you're
a who D it kind of person I challenge
you to get ahead of black
cake there are endless layers to Black
cake I just was hooked immediately
because it's a truly amazing
intersectional book
and those are the kinds of stories I
want to tell and the kinds of characters
I like to explore and bring to the
screen ready the hell is
[Music]
that what inspired me to tell the story
began as a feeling it came to life in
the form of these two teenagers who were
strong they had Big Dreams and they had
an incredible friendship I don't deserve
you you deserve the
world there are so many different
threads and themes running through the
story love betrayal secrecy family and
tradition here's the past may not blow
up our present casting for black cake
was an absolute Journey we scoured the
entire world to find cvy when I saw Mia
bring cvy to life with such care and
such maturity this young girl I just
knew she was cave the first time I saw
Mia I went oh my God that's
me I love watching a young mixed race
woman of similar Heritage to me and see
the beauty and opportunities that she's
able to grab onto and expand it for the
rest of my life I'm going to keep
looking over my shoulder it's important
to see people of color in different
positions on television and in stories
we have a marine biologist we have the
lawyer Benny who is an artist we have
people making these stries
in real life we just haven't seen it
translate on screen when the people
running these institutions picture their
next CEO chairman director they are not
imagining my
face when I met the character Benny in
the book I absolutely fell in love Benny
is queer and when we were talking about
her identity I loved that we didn't give
her a label I love that we are letting
her figure it out she's one of she's one
of my favorite characters I've ever
played we are all over the world over 50
years Italy Wales England Jamaica the
states the art Department the costumes
it was no easy feat it feels really
rewarding to tell a story that's
entrenched in Jamaican culture going
back in time and being able to relive it
to go over to Jamaica and where the
1960s closed was amazing the
high-waisted trousers the shirts I loved
every single thing the costume design on
this show it is real black cake has
something for everyone no matter who you
are no matter where you are you can
relate to this
story there's still so much that we
don't know your daughter is not only
missing she's a murder suspect she's not
a murderer it's juicy it's hot it's
steamy you know it's tasty it's it's
spicy it's it's kind of like well black
cake